how'd it go I'm using that was so sick
could I listen to you every day but
today I teared up four people have
already tweeted you should run for
president am I getting emails like crazy
it was really good
did you like it
what's up Facebook hats garyvee of
course one way I love you very much
no more yep just keep beating him please
look I'm gonna run I'm gonna FaceTime
you right now and say hi to him okay
max hi max how are you max cheating is
never a good idea it doesn't make it a
fair game and when you win when you
cheat it's not fun
okay you're not gonna cheat anymore okay
you want to play checkers you know what
max I don't think you're ever gonna beat
me in checkers in your whole life when
you play me I'm gonna destroy you
we'll see you better practice a lot okay
I love okay we love you in [ __ ]
my nephew's got it yeah max has it he's
got the Vaynerchuk competitive gene he's
super competitive I really genuinely
believe competition competitive nature
is a real blessing it's a real blessing
I took so much you know we've been
talking so much about self-awareness let
me let me break the wall here guys you
have a new like lens your lens looks
huge do I talk so much about
self-awareness and work ethic have been
themes but one of the great things about
this journey of filming so much is I get
to expand on some thoughts and truth is
it's a good segue from a little face
time with a little max novella you know
I really I don't think I've talked a lot
about competitive nature and competition
and what happens with the chemicals in
my body when I lose or when somebody's
beating me in something or outperforming
me it's like a it's almost like the
weird Incredible Hulk thing like it's
it's unbelievable what starts
transpiring
inside how much it suffocates me how how
driven I become how how motivated I am
by competition I would tell you that
when I started thinking that I was
whether I was right or wrong as we
became the wine shop in America and my
prime in the mid 2000s it just became
far less interesting the even
vaynermedia the last three or four years
being underestimated competing you know
it drives me so much
I think being competitive as a gift I
think a lot of parents in today's
society try to curtail it we get into a
way to heavy political correctness I
think it's I think there's good and
crying when you lose I think there's
good and spitting in your hand when you
shake the other team's hand cuz you're
mad at them something I get in third
grade I think it's appropriate to be a
sport a spoiled sport early on I think
um I think it should take you some time
to figure out how to calibrate those
emotions I think I think what we frown
on and draymond Green or other players
that could suspend or things of that
nature it's really their gift
you know I spend an enormous amount of
time and if I'm 40 years old now took me
well into my 30s to even begin to be
somewhat normal with my calibration of
my competitive spirit but I wouldn't
trade it for the world
and if I could say anything ten
anybody's watching this as you're
raising little ones or we're building a
team you know you know not you know
still hit a shortcut of me a it's a it's
a Russian saying everything's great when
it's in but everything is best when it's
balanced and so all these things we talk
about work ethic competitiveness please
understand I do believe that balance is
an important part I just think a little
keel turd to the insane or a little bit
further down the path of what is not
acceptable to most of you is a magic
zone I really do I really do think that
and so yeah hopefully we'll be fine
we'll find some more ways to start
thinking a little bit more about the
competitive thing because
it's a big factor cats so legendary so
New York where people outside of New
York going to be interviewed by Elvis
Durand legend super excited about it
hope you enjoy this e100 experience it's
awesome
I'll take a quick picture real quick
yeah thank you
we're pretty we're pretty we're pretty
low budget awesome thank you a lot of
course still of course it's a tough city
yes and and you know so if so if you can
afford it a lot of parents don't it's
such a tough battle for parents like
figuring out when to cut a child off or
not I talked to a lot of 56 year old
executives and it's one of the biggest
things in their mind you know you love
your kids you want you know it's like
everything else it's like gifts it's
like when I give my kids toys I still I
struggle with it I'm like I'm very
but it's really funny like I'm like I'm
never I'm never you know I'm not gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] these kids I'm not gonna
make them so and then and then Xander's
like can we go to Claire's thank you
zum-zum zum-zum czar like these little
toys that are like little little
characters little characters like Disney
characters and other characters in like
little form anyway nonetheless so I'm
like I go from like I'm not buying
anything to like see there's like daddy
can we go to Claire's I'm like of course
let's go and I'm bi I like buy Claire's
the store
now I'm like how much you want to store
Landers you know what I mean it's just
that's what happens all right how are
you I'm excited I'm like I mean as a
Jersey boy this is a big moment for me
too
well I'm like promoting it heavily right
now I'm like this is the bet and so many
my high school friends are like oh my
god you know it's gonna be fun
oh my god granny B's back so I'm so
excited to be back snapchat finally paid
attention
sounds like Gary's going on the radio I
was there when it was invented yes thank
you brother thank you very much my
pleasure what's your name
Garrett Garrett stuck with me six right
oh yeah big time
my wife started a business at home where
she's she's a physician assistant but on
the side she's selling like like
leggings or close to women online so
after your idea of going out to the
store like the thrift stores and selling
that flower shop
oh yes hey Kai put something out so I
started putting business cards and
they're around around town in Westfield
New Jersey and then started in Hoboken -
so [ __ ] have inspired so thank you
very much I think so happy man
hey so happy yeah thanks for saying
hello he loves you so much he said he
has ten closings this week he's a
realtor who soon
well spice every time I see him I'm
hakuna are you he found out my life is
built around this guy I'm like okay so I
needed any food Pharaoh would you say hi
to mama nobody yes his name is Sheldon
Sheldon it's Gary B I'm here with your
lovely wife all right now I need to know
why you're not here yeah yeah
why is Sheldon not here he didn't know
you were coming in but he sounds like
it's your fault you know he's my father
Sheldon I know hey Congrats on
everything man thanks for the love I
hope we can do get to meet someday my
life is getting weird you know what's
interesting about this Dirac I'm really
pumped we did this [ __ ] daily be
thing because I have a funny feeling a
year from today it's gonna seem
interesting like you know
figure out how to make them happen this
guy
the only had a dream made his dream come
true now he's helping other people
figure it out but came over and started
with very little to work with it has
everything to work with now and now he
wants to make sure we have the same
opportunities we are so excited to have
him here just talking about him coming
in today has caused quite a storm such a
pleasure
come on in don't jump don't mind the dog
I'm thrilled with the dog okay
hey guys first how are you today I'm
thrilled with the dog right you're
writing all these down I am do I have to
put these on yes no great phone call
well take it okay you want to do so wait
am i wait a minute real quick just to
set the tone you have a gold mic and
everybody else doesn't
I'm the pompous ass it's a pleasure I'm
excited to be here Gary uh first of all
Charlemagne is a very dear friend of
ours yes when he found out you're gonna
be on the show he's like you're gonna
love Gary Vee he's great we had a lot of
fun together and he's a really sharp
dude yeah he is and he's off on his own
in doing so well
so many different things and he gives
you a lot of credit that's super nice
but uh but I think his hustle and his
ambition has a lot to do with it but
I'll take any any credit I don't deserve
any day of the week who do you know
other than Gary who was a C D or F
student but because they just didn't
thrive in a preset like the test already
written for you Society but when they
came out of that and could make their
own rules come up with her own test for
themselves they could thrive and fly
like an eagle and that's the thing when
you live by other people's rules you're
not gonna give yourself a chance to take
a step back right now and think about
who we all admire in the world right
they're all people that punted the
system there are people that practice
singing since they were five there were
people that shot ten thousand
basketballs every morning it's always
that
it's always that 99% of the people right
now that are listening to this are
playing in the middle they're playing in
a game that was structured for them
they're risk adverse they fear and most
importantly they fear what other people
think
Ellis I think the best thing that ever
happened to me much like you with your
gold mic I didn't care what other people
said and and it's not because I didn't
respect it I actually I get feedback all
the time that might be negative this is
that I respect it I listen to it but at
the end of the day I'm just not built to
have it dictate my one at-bat at life
okay but I found yourself I found myself
I think you know it's funny and I
remember it was like fourth grade I got
an F on a science test and for some
unknown reason I mean remember you're
really young at fourth grade for some
weird reason I was like I just don't
care about Saturn and I have a funny
feeling it's not gonna matter to me
Wow there you go what about Uranus yeah
I care about Uranus that was set up so
perfect okay Gary Vaynerchuk is here
Gary Vee we call make sure you're
following him everywhere you can because
every day he gives us some thoughts that
really really catapult us into the day
and books yeah he's got books he's got
everything you don't want to be known as
a motivational speaker you're more of a
listen I've built a 50 million dollar
business and a hundred million dollar
business and I think a lot of people
when they hear motivational speakers and
things of that nature reaps a sound it
creeps me out I mean somebody who I love
practicality look I'm very motivating I
understand that you know mom and dad had
sex at the right moment and gave me that
DNA I get that but I like that I didn't
start telling the world you can do it
until I did it instead of what we see on
Instagram which is 22 year old life
coaches trying to tell us what to do
shai we talked about him when I was on
his show I talked about selling stuff in
your house on eBay I've gotten 50 to 100
emails in the last 30 to 60 days of
people auditing their home selling
everything they didn't want on eBay and
people literally making a thousand three
thousand ten thousand dollars to take a
vacation on literally just stuff like
like an owl lamp
everything was going so well in fly
referenceable damn we'll get rid of
everyone here I wish we had like another
five hours back
tomorrow's is this over yeah almost - I
know I hate that but no no no do me a
favor I feel like we're just getting the
East Coast hustlers going I think people
are like sitting at their desk right now
saying yeah I know it's like foreplay
with Gary Vee Oh excellent thank you
you had a great career let me tell you
something yeah use sharing your gift
like this is yeah
that was four and I listen to you every
day but today I teared up four people
were reading to me the usual run for
president d-roc I'm gonna surprise and
delight 25 people that mentioned the
radio with the pretzels Emery its Gary
Vaynerchuk um well how are you if you're
welcome to calls in one day I have a
really cool idea that you're gonna be
very excited about so my team and I are
gonna pick 25 to 50 random people right
now on Twitter that are commenting about
the interview and I'm gonna send them
your pretzels I love you back yes that's
appropriate normally people fall in love
with me very quickly well you'll be
hearing from us in a couple hours you're
welcome take it okay bye
so the super-fun dailyvee this is going
super meta we had a call in on the other
show Gary Vee what's on your mind today
Ann Marie about a company a pretzel shop
we I told the story about surprising and
alighting on Twitter now I'm gonna
surprise and delight people on Twitter
that listen to the show
with the pretzels from the show and
she's in Jersey I love it
hey India am i getting emails like crazy
it was really good
your sisters like you're really lucky to
know him it's super fun we all did
Oh everybody it's why listening to
society is a bad idea if you listen to
society the world's on fire and we're
all gonna die if you listen to society
everybody's gonna build Facebook and
snapchat then who do we listen to or
yourself listen to yours now the problem
is a lot of us don't like what ourselves
are telling the inner voice can be our
enemy that's right so so first and
foremost what what I think everybody
should do and even I'm saying this
action I'm giving myself advice right
now I'm just getting meta and stepping
away from this interview you can do
things that make you a little
uncomfortable way too many people have
made decisions without ever trying right
so that's that's one thing that I think
that's right and you have to taste
things like I love when people like oh I
hate sushi I'm like have you had it but
I know and so to me that's the most
fascinating thing of how humans are
right like that's what we do and so the
punchline is this look here's what
here's what I'll say on this little
genres we're jamming on it you have one
life